hey youtubers is Charlie so huge news
deadline is reporting that Benedict
Cumberbatch is basically gonna be Doctor
Strange so here's what's going on with
the movie Marvel is doing a special
announcement tomorrow I'll totally do a
video for it but they're likely gonna
announce what their phase 3 film slate
is as well as the official casting of
Doctor Strange they're basically closing
the deal like he isn't officially Doctor
Strange right now they're just in final
talks originally it was believed that
Joaquin Phoenix was going to be their
Doctor Strange but then that fell
through just in general if you're not
really familiar with Benedict
Cumberbatch's work or his more serious
drama work all you have to do is just
watch Sherlock series 3 it's all on
Netflix so it's totally easy to find you
should definitely check it out if you're
not a Sherlock fan you can totally watch
him tear up as the Dragons smile in
battle of the five armies this December
it really is funny to see how quickly he
blew up since he started doing Sherlock
a couple years ago it really has been a
pretty short time span but I'm a huge
fan of his I think he does amazing drama
I think he's really funny I think he can
hit all the bases Doctor Strange isn't a
big muscley character like Captain
America or Thor so you need a very
different kind of actor and yes there is
high potential for Doctor Strange
appearing in Avengers 3 he is part of
the Illuminati in the comics so
hopefully they'll do some sort of
Illuminati storyline at some point too
but let me know how you feel about the
idea of Benedict Cumberbatch becoming
Doctor Strange currently they're set to
begin filming early next year so they've
had to find their actor really fast
they're also gonna be airing new footage
from Avengers age of Ultron during
agents of shield originally they were
gonna debut the trailer but then it
leaked lots of drama but they're just
gonna roll out more new footage so right
now here's where the Doctor Strange
movie is they have a director scott
derrickson very awesome guy
the screenwriter is John Speights so
they basically have their director they
have the script that they want they just
needed their actor enter Benedict
Cumberbatch he was one of my fantasy
picks early on but it really was a
fantasy like he's actually doing a stage
play for a lot of next year so I think
scheduling was a big problem it was
widely reported last year that Marvel
really wanted to work with Benedict
Cumberbatch if the opportunity ever
arose but typically with an actor this
popular right especially right now
just scheduling is a nightmare even
getting all the Avengers together for a
ders movie is crazy so hopefully we'll
find out in the next couple of days
whether or not benedict cumberbatch
signed his name in blood on a Marvel
contract the interesting thing about
this big Marvel showcase tomorrow is
that a lot of people think that they
might start doing their own events away
from comic-con let their own industry
event like Disney does with d23 like now
they're making Star Wars announcements
through d23 they didn't bring any big
Star Wars Episode seven stuff to
comic-con because they didn't really
need to think they have their own big
event to do that ad so Marvel might
start doing that themselves to let me
know whether you like that idea or not
you know Marvel doing its own big
special event away from comic-con it's
just about Marvel stuff well you guys
think about that here are my top five
Doctor Strange stories
number five essential Doctor Strange
stories vol 1 this is like the collected
works of Stan Lee and Steve Ditko's
original run on the character the
original origin story I think regardless
of what they do obviously they're gonna
have a Stan Lee cameo I'm sure it'll be
ridiculous as it always is ridiculous
and awesome whenever they wrote this
story though it was like this early 60s
benchmark for weird it was kind of like
a guardians of the galaxy of the day
like in the way that guardians of the
galaxy the movie kind of turned the
superhero genre on its head that's kind
of what Stan Lee did with Doctor Strange
back in the 60s this story has a whole
lot of long speechifying which doesn't
really fit in a lot of modern superhero
genre movies but because it's likely
that they'll get Benedict Cumberbatch
and he excels a dialogue they might have
some fun with that
just watch an episode of Sherlock he
speaks at the speed of light and it
sounds so good number four triumphant
torment this is a little bit trippy and
because of rights issues they'd have to
change it a little because it involves
Doctor Strange getting doctor dooms help
to rescue dooms mother from Mephisto it
was actually done by hell boys Mike
Minneola and it reads like this super
high drama romance Downton Abbey style
crossed with a dream you could only have
if you were really really stoned but
think about this premise Doctor Strange
and Doctor Doom go to hell that would
just make an amazing movie obviously
they couldn't use dr. doom because Fox
but they could always substitute someone
else like Scarlet Witch number three a
separate reality most people think of
this as Frank Brunner's run he was the
artist not the writer though I would
totally put it up there with Brian
Kevin's run which came much later but
the story is this excellent blend of a
lot of the science fiction aspects of
the Marvel Universe and the
the elements like magic which is
basically what dr. strange is bringing
to the marvel universe Scarlet Witch is
kind of magic I'll be interested to see
how they explain that
and those Inhumans too so Marvel has a
lot of work and bringing magic to the
movie universe number two flight of
bones this is part of the great noir
Marvel Knights miniseries era that
invoked this really cool detective story
a la Sherlock that set Doctor Strange
against Dormammu think of it is like
Doctor Strange written like a Sherlock
Holmes story and number one the oath by
Brian cape on this was an amazing
retelling of the origin story like in a
much more modern setting it solved a lot
of the problematic aspects of magic that
didn't really fit in what the Marvel
Universe was doing at the time it also
does a great job of balancing a lot more
of the philosophical aspects of wielding
limitless power with crazy magical
battles and other dimensions so it's
like this really trippy stuff that the
Marvel movie universe hasn't done yet
really the big issue with Doctor Strange
stories that sets it apart from Captain
America or Iron Man or the other Marvel
movies is that he can't just punch his
problems away plus he's a really dark
character like there's this balance of
super darkness and light inside of him
so really the fun teases is that
Benedict Cumberbatch gets to be a Marvel
hero but he also gets to be a really
dark Marvel hero much darker than any of
the Marvel superheroes we've seen so far
plus he gets to be absolutely insane
Doctor Strange is definitely a crazy
character there are a whole lot of other
big things that they could talk about at
that big event tomorrow like a Black
Panther movie as well as a female Marvel
movie I know everyone wants Captain
Marvel I think Black Widow is another
big likelihood I'll totally be doing
another video based on whatever
announcements they make so be sure to
subscribe to get that there will be some
new avengers footage after agents of
shield so i'll do a video for that too
so lots of Marvel stuff happening this
week it's gonna be really awesome I know
they haven't said a lot about guardians
2 in a while they've already announced a
release date for that movie I know
everyone's really wondering whose star
Lords father's gonna be and yes he's
gonna figure into that movie
currently best odds are on Adam warlock
but that's a bit of a stretch lately
they've been a whole lot of rumors about
the Marvel Universe and how they might
split Avengers 3 into a couple movies
and they might not even include the
regular Avengers it's likely that Marvel
will explain a lot of that tomorrow the
idea is that right now with Avengers age
of Ultron they're gonna
actually the team and they're gonna
throw the movie universe into chaos so
they won't be able to fight Thanos until
they come back together and that's gonna
take many many more movies so just in
general I wouldn't plan on an Infinity
Gauntlet storyline for a long time maybe
even Avengers for like phase four way
way off like we haven't even hit phase
three yet just in case you guys haven't
seen it for the billion time you can
click here to watch the Avengers 2
trailer again so good and you can click
here for my top 5 guardians of the
galaxy 2 stories that I think they
should do thank you so much for watching
so let's all high-five and I will see
you guys tomorrow
you